the clip went viral as they say
you can't just sit here and cry oh i
can't so just sit here and cry
two million hits in the first week and
then the parodies started
one from the philippines got 12 million
hits
and the late night comedy guys had a
field day with it
come on baby wawa don't be such a baby
[Applause]
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be
all right eureka's update is
[Applause]
hello i'm your new commanding officer
captain seth dozerman
my motto is simple efficiency efficiency
efficiency could probably just
say it once are you making fun of my
stutter oh uh drift you i don't have a
stutter boom
i've already established my authority
through my amazing sense of humor well
done sir
welcome to the nine-nine i'm sergeant
terry jeffords and i'm not interested
i have no use for people i find people
weird and confusing
i live my life by numbers you see this
watch it tells me how many calories i
burn at any time
question how many calories you think i
burned walking from there to there you
female closest to me
oh three three
[Laughter]
try 0.8 numbnuts i've made promises to
my superiors that i most certainly
cannot keep that's why i need you
idiots to work twice as hard no no
strike that
four times as hard no no no strike that
i need you morons
to work eight times harder than you've
ever worked
and your entire life i'm having a heart
attack
yeah i'm having a heart attack get back
to work
get a doctor but
i like you i could tell from the moment
i walked in here that we were one in the
same
detail oriented love crunching numbers
bet your apartment's immaculate
probably eat off the floor and i do yeah
i'm gonna handle this for you okay i'm
gonna
send out a dozer blast
hey everyone stop talking about
peralta's personal life
dozerblast over
wow thank you very much sir and might i
just say that this
has been a dozer blast i saw what you
did right there
get back to work okay you two have been
in this evidence locker for
hey what nothing oh nothing you were
just making out with peralta
there's that candy bar rapper i was
looking for oh santiago what are you
doing here
so i guess it is hoes before it chose
with you friend
now i understand why nothing gets done
in this precinct the detectives are too
busy frenching with each other
you know what your little honeymoon is
over
because as long as i'm here you two are
done
and i'm gonna be here a long long long
long
long long long long
oh this is a heart attack this right
here this is a heart attack oh it's a
big one
i'm gonna get help sir it's all right
we're getting help
tell my wife that i love her
work ethic
oh oh my god tom oh tom i'm so sorry
i'm so oh my god let me help you
am i bleeding um i'm bleeding i'm so
sorry please tell me you're beautiful
i didn't i taste pennies this looks good
this is you're gonna look better than
when you came in
hey you wanted like um frankenstein
stitches cause of halloween right
really it's not bad at all i'd really
want to hurt you i would have sent all
your contacts that
video of you spitting out that bite of
hot pizza
hey you know what i still owe you a
wedding gift is there anything on the
registry that you still need
go back in time and don't ruin my
wedding tom i'm sorry okay
i'm really sorry back then i was like a
little messed up and i think i was kind
of drunk at the wedding too a little bit
you're really drunk away um i was hurt
then but i'm not now
i'm dating a blonde guy and i just i
wish the best for both
you and you know i don't even know her
name all right
i know i heard you too and and uh
i'm sorry i was recording this
conversation in case you threatened me
but now i'm gonna stop oh
just tell me about blondie who who's
this guy his name is josh
and he is an attorney for nba players he
is definitely
confident very confident almost too
confident
like he can be sometimes a little
obnoxious i think but he's very funny
uh not funny in a way that you like want
to laugh all the time but you're kind of
like ah
offends me so he's a jerk no he's not a
jerk i like him he's just i wouldn't
necessarily like curl up with him and
watch breaking bad don't say anything
about bringing but i haven't seen season
five yet you are so weird about it no
you're doing it right now don't say it
don't spoil it
[Music]
you say one word it ruins the whole
thing i stopped talking about you done
you done we're not talking about it okay
who's that guy he's some cheesy old
loser who's in this friend like
the 90s the 90s you kill me from a
circle around me
dancing you always want to dance with
[Music]
obstetrics and gynecology tom
roll surgery
oh god okay that she's your loser is the
guy almost married tom
tom oh god tom
tom are you okay oh hey
hey hey how are you i'm okay are you all
right
legs are great yeah you're doing really
well cool i bought a ring oh is it
bleeding
oh yeah it bleeds a lot yeah i have like
no pillowcases at my house yes so what
have you been up to
i moved yeah westchester wasn't really
doing it for me anymore so yeah now i
live in a furnished apartment
yeah back in the city uh right across
the street from the holocaust museum
oh no we're in by the entrance it's by
the entrance so it's people are very
happy going in
uh how is your wife doing she's good
she's good yeah she's gone
she moved back to serbia but that's cool
whatevs
you know i mean now i get to do what i
want to do which is hang out with my
friends
all right talk to my lawyer sell the
boat that me and my dad made
last time i saw you you're expecting a
baby yeah it turns out the baby looked a
lot like her ex-boyfriend boris lowko
hey that's awful no no it's a good thing
you know that means they were sleeping
with each other
while we were married i get the
implications i didn't even masturbate
when we were married
yeah it's pretty awesome loser
all right that's just what we do man
he's just having a good time see
just playing around with chef chef head
okay sorry i'm sorry
these guys love me is tom's friend
anyone here can talk
i have no friends we should leave here
last time i was here someone shot me
carol i knew you wouldn't forget about
me today no non-essential chad or liz
i'm having the worst flight of my career
we got wind shear lightning severe
turbulence the inflight meal was a
frittata
oh my god at night lizzie if something
were to happen i i just
i want you to know that i i need you to
go to raleigh to my apartment and just
clear out all the porn before my mom
gets there
that's it yeah i also need you to tivo
bones for me in case i survive no
you know what carol today is a very
special day and you should have known
that and you should also know that you
can't use cell phones on planes
no that's just something we tell
passengers
hello hold on
all right yeah i think i just screwed up
something with my girlfriend you know
i've always loved you
not now kevin
you